everybody likes
new inventions new technology
people will never be replaced by
machines
in the end life and business are about
human connections
and computers are about trying to murder
you in a lake
and to me the choice is easy
okay michael why don't you start us off
um
that wasn't much of an introduction
ladies and gentlemen your boss michael
scott oh still lame okay
all right um
thank you ryan
for that wonderful introduction
okay um
today we're going to be talking
about
powerpoint
powerpoint powerpoint powerpoint
yes i forgot about ryan's presentation
and yes it would have been nice to do
well with the first presentation that
he'd given me
but you know what else would have been
nice
winning the lottery
and the best way to start is to hit
start
and up comes
the tool bar that's what she said what
we have to do
here is go to run
and then
you look up to
powerpoint
and we are in we are going to register
you hit register
updates are ready i should update
um
estimated time 12 minutes so this should
take about five or ten minutes
this is the first time you've opened
powerpoint
why
you didn't prepare a presentation at all
did you know what i had a really rough
night and my boss can back me up on that
i'm your boss
my other boss mr figaro you have another
job
what i do between 5 30 p.m and 1 a.m is
nobody's business but mine and my other
businesses
are your collective waitress
you cannot have a second job if it
affects your work here it won't it did
already okay honestly
it is unlikely that i was going to
figure this out anyway yes
it is true i michael scott am signing up
with an online dating service thousands
of people have done it and i am going to
do it i need a username
and i have a great one
little kid lover that way people will
know exactly where my priorities are at
i finally
broke down and bought myself
a plasma
tv
check it out
i actually hung this on the wall myself
it's good i want to show you something a
lot of people in the room you need more
space
voila right into the wall wow sometimes
i will just stand here and watch
television for hours i love it
i love this tv jim can you come in here
please
hi jim
hello
i am harvey a computer jim sucks
so exactly oh wow
that's so rude i'm sorry i can't control
him yeah he can you know i get pam for
this
pam
pam you look very hot today
pam meet harvey this is michael's new
friend
great
me so horny me love you long tim oh whoa
oh
that is gross who's long tim
damn it
long time me loboy long time oh well you
should bring long tim in one day nope
i'd love to meet mom yeah right yeah
you ruined a funny joke you get out of
my office
okay
bye harvey
boobs
proceed straight
well we're all for six
last chance is the elmhurst country club
other side of the lake on the southeast
side i don't get it
i really don't get it i thought this
would work
do everything i had at that guy nothing
that's how it goes sometimes you know
you lose everything and everything falls
apart and eventually you die and no one
remembers you that is a very good point
make a right turn
wait wait wait wait wait no no no it
means bear right
not there it said right it said take a
right
no no no no no look it it means go up
to the right bare right over the bridge
and hook up with 307. make a right maybe
it's a shortcut dwight it said go to the
right it can't mean that there's a leg
there
remain calm i have trained for this
okay
exit the window
[Music]
are you okay swim for it
i got you oh my gosh
come on
come on
[Music]
you sure you're okay fine
good
that is what's most important
did you get the rental insurance
because that is pretty important too at
a time like this
what a disaster this whole thing
i call a gab
these people just don't realize what a
gift basket means they don't get it look
at that stillworks old-fashioned cell
phone yeah
what about that last guy erin is he a
jerk
i don't even know if i want it
their website is so easy yeah well you
can have your technology jackass look
where it got us yes uh we need a cab at
lake scranton at the end of east
mountain road
in the lake hang up
you know what we're gonna do
we're walking back
we're walking back to that office and
we're going to reclaim our gift basket
yes we're going to take what's
rightfully ours we're going to take a
stand dwight
we're going to take a stand
[Applause]
this morning the phone guy comes in
and he shows michael that our phones
have a pa function
and they just
left
is your captain speaking the office will
be flying at an altitude of two stories
look out your left hand window and you
will see vance refrigeration
i am the ghost of salesmen past do not
come near me
yes michael scott for dr joshua please
hello doctor i was just following up
about my mole again
now i was looking online about sebaceous
sniffs
i have not been squeezing it
could i stick it with a pen
don't be wondering to the principal's
office your mother called and it appears
that you wet the bed again so you have
to get home to wash your sheep because
they're yellow and they're wet with your
urine
and at six foot six on the university of
north carolina
that's pretty funny hey you know what
did i drop my uh
what the heck
is that uh did you find it i didn't
i'll look somewhere else all right all
right
okay well we can do questions okay very
good first hand up sir as a company that
primarily distributes paper how have you
adapted your business model to function
in an increasingly paperless world
we can't overestimate the value of
computers yes they are great for playing
games and forwarding funny emails
but real business is done on paper okay
write that down
you